guess what's in here I am boxing all six
colors of the brand new iPhone 10 are
I'm really excited because this phone is
so beautiful and I love all of these
colors I also have something very
special I've got some fantastic unboxing
knives for today I thought we would get
really that's to definitely Dexter and
I'll just do an approved I have two
other iPhone 10 hour videos in case you
missed those I have my iPhone 10 hour
review and a vlog that I shot on the
iPhone 1000 so this is extremely
exciting and a very very rare thing I
don't do giveaways very often but my
friend Jonathan he is also doing an
unboxing of all six colors so we decided
that we're gonna partner up do a
giveaway if you guys want a chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to both mine and Jonathan's channel like
both of our videos be sure to comment on
each one of them while you're at it you
might as well hit the bell for some
extra bonus points so Thank You Jonathan
for the motivation and thank you for all
of your incredible videos we look
forward to sending you a brand new phone
we'll let you guys pick whatever color
you want to so don't worry now the
moment that you've all been waiting for
which color should we unbox first you
guys would think that I bought these
specifically for this video you would
think that but now I've actually already
had these so I think we'll start with a
small one first we'll go with the blue
[Music]
this knife actually matches it matched
it more perfect this is was not planned
I think I bought these knives two years
ago never use them
[Music]
looks like yellows next these knives are
just so beautiful I still think of the
yellow wiping my favorite so this knife
doesn't match quite as well but it still
has some of the yellow accents on it
[Music]
this looks to me like it would be the
coral phone nice fall day
pick your cousin this night you really
love knives and I'm not going to change
for you the coral color is very
interesting because depending upon what
the lighting is like it'll look peach or
a look pink or to look a little bit more
orange color knife swag I don't have a
red knife I used to I had a team valor
knife but I don't know where I went
pink is sort of a shade of red this is
the product red iPhone and I love this
one so much because not only is it
incredible red color but it's also for
charity I'm a huge fan of all of the
product red products this is different
than the other ones they've got the
product red insert it's so great it's
like I'm not even a huge fan of the
color red but whatever they've done
these past two iPhones the red is just
so great
it's such a great read definitely does
not match the sinaitic at all moving
onto this purple knife we don't have a
purple iPhone
unfortunately so I guess I'll unbox the
white one no I'm sorry desk you've been
abused Oh God oh this bread knife is
vicious
Wow okay well if I had to pick a color
out of all of these because if you
haven't noticed I love an all-white
aesthetic and this phone is really
really nice
I'm even asking what the heck I'm gonna
do with all of these things does anybody
want them what a gift
does not quite match this looks
fantastic and last but not least we've
got the black I showed this one looks
incredible as well
here it is the last one of the bunch
this is the all-black it's really really
great-looking and yes it does in fact
match my knife
here they are we've got them all in box
they are such incredibly vibrant colors
that one of the things that I'm thinking
about doing with this is sort of making
them into an art piece which I know is
kind of crazy and you're like Justine I
don't have an iPhone and you're gonna
turn your iPhone through an art piece
you guys always think that if I buy the
phones I'm going to return them but I'm
not
I bought them specifically for this
video so I want to kind of do like a
framed photo with all of them in it
sounds silly but I think it'll look
really cool for now let's turn all of
these on so that we can see their
wonderful new backgrounds which is one
of the cool things about all of these is
they have custom colored backgrounds to
match the color of the phones hey what
did you do this weekend I don't want to
talk about it but a great color
it's about all six of these which one is
your favorite color because I'm still
honestly I really like the yellow a lot
and it's gonna shock him to see this
color of a phone I'm not sure of this
colors for everyone but if you like most
people are gonna put cases immediately
on their phones
and here's the black
[Music]
and that's been at least the coral which
you guys already saw because I've posted
a bunch about this on my channel already
so now that these are all unboxed and on
let's take them outside and get some
slim will be rolled because you guys
know that's something that I just can't
resist we're trying to film this video
people are footin and hollering there
guys like screaming out of their cars
yeah beautiful smiles now you saw those
phones baby girl I said I will fight you
right now I'm not selling these phones
I'm trying to show you YouTube video
subscribe to my channel
I mean you are holding it like you're
handing six phones on the street corner
let me live my best life
maybe you can make a profit
[Music]
FBI is enjoyed this unboxing I've had a
lot of fun doing this I am so excited
about the new iPhone 10 R and the new
iPhone 10s and 10's max all of these
phones are really great phones and I
feel like whichever one you decide to
get you're going to be very happy with
but as a reminder I am doing a giveaway
with Jonathan on both of our channels we
are giving away a ten are on mine
Anna ten are on his so be sure to
subscribe to mine and his comment on
both of our videos like the videos be
sure to hit the bell do all of the
things that youtubers constantly tell
you to do we will be choosing winners
and sending the color of your choice out
to you probably put the Swedish washer
if I ever plan to actually use them for
food
[Music]